this video is sponsored by Hong Kong
impacts third Hong Kong impact third is
the free-to-play action RPG and they are
just celebrating their second year
anniversary yes you may have seen them
on my channel before but they've just
chopped a new update and when I say
update it is absolutely massive which
includes a new post honk I apocalyptic
setting that takes place eight years
after honk I impact the Odyssey and a
brand new Valkyrie de Randall are you
ready for this [ __ ] bass drop hit not
only that but an hour features improved
3d aerial focused combat that adds way
more to the air juggling mechanics that
were there before I think it's actually
insane just how much has changed since I
last worked with them because they've
almost added a new games worth of stuff
since then and not only that but this
bad boys now also cross-platform yes you
can play this on either mobile or PC
veteran plays a login since January 23rd
we'll be able to claim a ton of benefits
including an STF valkyrie hero and you
can also use the exclusive redemption
code below for free crystals this
redemption code is only available for 24
hours after the release of this video so
if you want to get on all the available
freebies click that link in the
description to download it today and
with that said let's get on with the
videos hey guards aren't you working
oh well you know the world is going
crazy right now and everyone's in
quarantine so I don't want to risk going
to work you know I'm just I'm just
trying to do my part but your office is
right there
oh [ __ ] hey guys as your friendly
neighborhood degenerate here it's spring
2020 and the entire world is practicing
social distancing while you're already a
fifth dan black belt challenger tier
Grand Master of the thing so while the
whole world's on fire and fun has
officially been made illegal it's time
to do our parts by showing the world
what we call a pro quarantine move it's
time to watch them sees no anime players
player player players player and player
clear gamers gamers gamer player players
problem gaming oh there's certainly a
problem we got a damn gamer you know
sometimes you see this thing which on
paper should kick [ __ ] ass but
somehow doesn't quite come together well
how about a record 7 meets Carolyn
Tuesday with mechs driven by the power
of rock music by all intents and
purposes I should love this show an
anime original with an F LCOS soundtrack
references to classic rock from Jimi
Hendrix Led Zeppelin and a mid-2000s
anime vibe that is so rare to find
nowadays but something about it just
doesn't quite hit the right notes maybe
it was the ugly CG mechs maybe also
blond monsters maybe it was the
forgettable characters maybe it was the
writing or the concept this cool that an
OST that is screaming my kind of vibes I
really want to love this show
I just really hope it pulls it together
because this should be [ __ ] awesome
you know what I got to be honest with
you guys for the first time in a while
this season is actually quite safe it
wasn't really anything offensively bad
or weird this time but we've got a lot
of interesting stuff so you know what
we're just gonna keep the memes light
this episode and do a rundown of what's
worth watching PA works are hitting us
with a new anime only original about two
genius antisocial inventor taking part
in a Transcontinental race over America
in sin coos Bizarre Adventure steam
Balrog I see a lot of promise in this
one just looking at the characters and
vehicle designs everything is so vibrant
and full of personality it looks like
this is gonna be animators with a bit of
redline sprinkled in there in
very unique setting of good old Japanese
speaking 1920s America ever since
shirobako
I feel like PA works just hasn't quite
hit the mark with this anime only
originals but with the passion I feel
being put into this and viola ever
Gardens composer ever incor doing the
OST I've got a good feeling about this
one to give our usual rundown on sequels
out the way car gear is back we've got
fruit basket the book he's a guy is
anyone still actually watching shokugeki
how have you not given up on this yet oh
we also got our easier season to can't
forget about that
what's reezy row alright class who here
has an unhealthy hobby of watching
things that emotionally obliterate them
you have watch a single episode of an
anime and even though nothing
substantial geomatic happens you think
to yourself yeah the show's gonna
[ __ ] destroy me sing yesterday for me
was something that quietly emanated that
this could be something special even if
on paper it's just a slice of life
romance drama with characters that are
past adolescence and into adulthood
there's no dramatic premise there's no
melodrama to target your heartstrings
it's just been a while since I've seen
writing so emotionally resonant it just
captures post adolescence so painfully
well there were three times or
characters we'll just throw out this
line and without dwelling on it or
making a big deal you think crap that
hits way too close to home none God's
insane you get watch it on air he's sure
came in as even 10 or a [ __ ] war it or
not there he Cassone not any game
adjudication or dog or on damage even
like is it's gonna Anissa each episode
has been so laid in substance it feels
like you've gone through a whole season
in just 20 minutes that by the end of
the first episode I was already 100%
invested this is an absolutely beautiful
show and I'm pleasantly surprised that
after all the cute girls do cute things
showed Ogikubo is known for
they've immediately found their groove
with depressed adults do you existential
crisis things still have no idea what
the title actually means though now for
a show I had no idea would have any
interest in a workplace comedy about
radio broadcasting see what I love about
show like this is that I could have no
prob
knowledge or interest in the subject
matter it tackles but the main lead is
such an engrossing and entertaining
character I can't help but appreciate
the skill and talent that goes into
being a great radio host by watching her
journey in becoming one mad props to a
voice actress who is as impressive as
the narrative needs her to be with a
voice performance that is absolutely
captivating it feels like you're
listening to a rocket of performance
every time she opens her mouth while
sucker punching you with this completely
in your face machine gun delivery and
now a poem to send to your quarantine
crush roses are red violets are blue
chorus chapter this is the kind of hot
edgy mess my 16 year old self would have
absolutely eaten up so it's a good thing
I haven't actually mentally aged since
then so far this has followed the edgy
death game formula to a tee gratuitous
violence horny as [ __ ] here's what the
spineless when P protagonist normally
looks like in any other show here's what
a spineless wimpy protagonist actually
looks like to immensely unstable anime
girl in a death game but even so this
one actually looks like it's got the
production values to back it up look at
this fight what's most impressive isn't
just the choreography or the animation
but it's how they've convey the sense of
weight so well you can absolutely feel
the power behind these punches a furry
beatdown has never looked this good also
I've got to give a shout-out to Claire
normally we just see an over the top
discount yuno gasai knockoff but
sometimes you find a character that's
just the perfect amount of crazy that
every part of your being is like this is
a bad idea this is definitely a bad idea
she is not worth the risk
what do you think dick I wanna risk it
all scared
yet somehow turned on I don't know man
it's that smile that something about
that damn smile wait a minute in
conclusion don't stick your dick in
crazy
that crazy stick herself in you
[Music]
you know you cool yeah I think it's
Carol that big cat rescued of course
we've got a new original ISA guy this
season with a female protagonist this
time and my first thought when I saw
this was man I'm pretty sure the style
was longer than her original lifespan I
didn't think a reverse harem ISA car
would be my thing but it had a
surprisingly interesting concept about a
girl who's reincarnated into an anime
game as the villain s and having played
the game in her previous life she
realizes is that all the endings to the
game lead to her dying or being exiled
so she has to try and Stein skates away
into a new possible ending I think what
hurts the most though is that her harem
is already more believable than 90% of
every other harem I've seen because she
reminded me that unlike most other bland
harem protagonists she's actually active
and there's more that goes into
collecting love interests than just
existing in season two of I'm not a
furry bar lipsticks are slowly building
the fairy monopoly licensing triggers
adaptation of the furry vs. gamers
tick-tock war you know I put a give it
to trigger they've done some great stuff
but a lot of it can be hit or miss but
we always end up watching them anyway
and this will be no different because I
mean is trigger if it's good will praise
them to heaven and if it's bad we'll
just say a-1 pictures made it honestly
though this does look on the more
promising side of things people are just
gonna say that this is the sequel to the
world of B stars but what they don't
realize is that B stars is just the
sequel to the world of interspecies
reviewers Khakassia gato is a new show
from the creator of sayonara zetsubou
sensei about a manga artist who's trying
to hide from his innocent daughter the
fact that he's the creator of some kind
of famous lewd manga or something almost
easy master you know I can't tell ya
this is gonna be a nice wholesome comedy
or if it's gonna shred my heart to
pieces
probably both we have a new comedy about
a sugar daddy detective who's
effectively figured out how to pay to
win at life I'm not really sure how else
to describe the show
I'm rich yet Audi looks like the Moy
flavor of this month is cute girls the
fishing and cute girls do baseball if
you're just looking for some cute anime
girls having some harmless baseball fun
[Music]
you know even with all the cancellations
we've had this might be one of the most
balanced seasons we've had for a while
no one's onra is dominating too much and
there's good enough variety that there's
at least one show for everyone but you
may be wondering if there's any other
shows I'm keeping an eye on in spring
well there might be one it's been a
while since I've been this interested to
see how an anime will turn out Tower of
God is the first anime project that's
come from a collaboration between crunch
roll and webtoons he focuses around a
tower that said whoever can climb all
levels can be granted any desire they
wish participants have to pass various
tests on every level to ascend and just
from the first few episodes you can
really get a sense that a lot of thought
has been put into the world building the
power systems and filling it with a very
colorful cast of characters there's a
talking alligator a badass lizard girl
dude he seems to have a very complicated
family past and then there's the main
character who's repeatedly risking his
life in the tower just so he can get the
chance to see some blond chick it's time
to sim so far it's giving off some heavy
Hunter hunter vibes in a good way not to
mention Kevin Peng keen is also doing
the soundtrack so he's got a lot of
things going for it this looks like it
could be some premium shown in junk
foods but what interests me more is what
it could mean for the wider anime
landscape Webb juice is a platformer
that has popped up exclusively during
the age of the Internet originating from
Korea it was a place where artists could
upload their own stories and has been
the place that has popularized Korean
web comics nowadays is populated with
stories from people all over the world
but the fact that Tower of God is the
first of a few shows to be adapted on
the platform this could spell a new era
of this industry because this opens up a
whole new world of possibilities solo
leveling is and webtoons but you can bet
if this goes down well there's gonna be
a lot of interest korean manhwa
adaptations in general why not be a
far-off dream and hell what about the
world of chinese Manoir anything could
be free game with this experiment pans
out so make no mistake if this turns out
to be a good adaptation and a massive
hit which it very much looks like it
could be this
be one of the most important anime of
recent times and the show we look back
to that signaled the start of a new
landscape in the anime sphere also Yuri
is my girl I'm just going to claim her
now we all cool with that I don't even
care if she comes packaged in with a
little dwarf helper
huh hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again to Hong Kong impact
third for sponsoring this video
I think the work they are doing is
[ __ ] fantastic and they are really
pushing the boundaries of what you can
do with mobile gaming so if this looks
interesting to you click the link in the
description to give it a go and check
out the massive update that they just
dropped and with that said thank you
very much to wall time we Bala juice
Ricky Robert on Borg Joe Augustine Mike
elfin zob mondo and everyone else in my
patron for helping to support me for
this month I hope quarantines be
treating you well I don't know what the
[ __ ] to do of myself anymore
there's only so much anime I can watch
while going [ __ ] insane ok dad Rhys
you've got a [ __ ] haircut before
quarantine started say how about you
mean ya want to say hi
well I hope you guys have something to
keep you company during these tough
times what the [ __ ] is quarantine done
to us